This is just the exact same slop over and over and over again.
He literally has a special avatar with the Ethan Hassan destiny
spaghetti that he's serving up again for the thousandth time
that he's reheating. Stop trying to think. Stop trying to make
this complicated. Dude, I Did I have a stroke? He just said something
totally nonsensical. I think I had a stroke. Anissa stays winning.
Glam got rid of bun. Watching people sell their souls is very
funny to me. It's just good. It's a good watch. It's a good watch
every
With that being said, I think we have time now. We can slip into
this Doreio vod, all right? Something goes back and forth with
a chatter called out his level of expertise in international
Let's Let's get into it. Let's get into it. Let's see what his
rage moment here was. weapons that could be utilized against
Iran are already turned.
Uh Hassan, this isn't content. Why do these people care about
what your non-expert has ass has to say all about all this? You're
cosplayer, bro. Quit
Actual base true fact fact. >> he has a degree, doesn't
he?
Like I I'm pretty sure he's got a degree, actually. Why are we
Why are we pretending that he just didn't go to school for this?
This is one that's like, all right, well
I mean, we could just time this guy out or probably the best
case scenario here is ignoring him. And then Hasan [__]
clicks it, opens it up, and he's probably going to give a very
funny 2-minute explanation.
If I catch you
Hassan, this is like Hassan's content is he just picks random
chatters who disagree with them to fight with. How do you not
know that? This guy literally has a PhD in Hassanology.
How do you not know that that's like half of his content is just
finding to fight with in his chat every day? Like He just gets
like irrationally angry at chatters every day. you If I look
at your your uh comments in the Asmongold chat and I find out
that you're glazing his analysis, will you feel a sense of shame?
>> Oh my god, wait. Wait. Wait. He pulled him off the screen.
He had it on the screen before he even started talking. That
guy just immediately started typing >> Rent free. It pops
up for a second. >> Asmongold chat and I find out that
you're glazing his analysis, will you feel a sense of shame?
Okay, so immediately you could just show it. Immediately you
could What is that that he's typing >> right there?
Oh, he's No, he's talking to an individual chatter. But the person
comes in and writes rent free. Very, very funny. Again, Hasan
[__] was calling out somebody about a week ago. We
covered it on the channel. where he uh the person was writing
a bunch of Islamophobic sh- in his chat, and Hassan's response
to that was so bad it went viral for hating the American troops
and like veterans because instead of just acting normal, he then
started a whole like measuring contest bashing veterans for having
PTSD.
Uh 15 years out from Iraq, eat my balls.
Do you even have your balls remaining or did a IED explode them
for you, dumbass? Shut the [__] up talking about
Islam.
You are an infinitely bigger terrorist than any random Muslim
ever could be,
Shut your big ass up. Go enjoy your PTSD
You Imagine having the audacity to be like, yeah, I went to Iraq.
I went to Iraq, and it's actually Islam that's the biggest danger.
You're the danger,
You're a danger to your family. He then started a whole like
measuring contest bashing veterans for having PTSD
uh and making extremely vague all-encompassing arguments on one
specific person uh impacting a larger group of people. So that
went super viral, and it wasn't because of the Islamophobia,
and he ended up
Sure. He was talking about that one specific person. I Okay.
I I thought that was funny. I don't know why you'd tell me about
that, but >> of it inadvertently by having a bad reaction.
Now Hasan [__] is still kind of doing the exact same
tactics here, but this is more of a him problem. shame
>> His lolcow gene is winning. Yeah, that's a good way
to put it. >> No. Cuz Dude, Nicholas Doreio is such a racket.
He's got like
He's got like 12 different memes he does and and references,
and he just trains you on those memes, okay?
And then he just recycles them over and over and over again.
This is just the exact same slop over and over and over
Lolcow gene. Family Guy reference. Lolcow gene. Uh huh Bowblax.
Bowblax. What's the guy's name? Flamenco. Bowblax, Flamenco,
John Swan.
Okay, Family Guy reference.
Lolcow gene.
Oh, there's probably like three or four others. I don't watch
enough of this guy. But I swear to god he just rolls through
these exact same like 12 jokes, and he just keeps re-serving
them up, reheating them, putting them back out there every single
stream.
Every single stream, man. There's just no work. This is There's
nothing inspiring about this content whatsoever.
And I'm saying that. I I roll out of bed. I show up on stream.
I try, okay? I try. I try to get some new references. I try to
do new things. I try to do new voices sometimes.
With Nicholas, it's the same bit over and over and over again,
okay? That's what his mom's enjoy. It's like he Yeah, he just
appeals to the lowest common denominator. These people who show
up for the same thing over and over and over again. It's like
they watch Nicholas Doreio instead of watching reruns of like
Friends and House and The Office, right? Like some white women
just found this guy, and they're like, oh well, instead of watching
The Office for the 55th time, I'm going to just watch Nicholas
Doreio cuz it'll be the same thing over and over again, and then
I don't really need to learn anything or think anything. He can
just do the same memes over and over again, like The
He He's just like The Office.
Dude, kill me. This is true. I'm not a miss a lot uh I am not
a map off I'm a political off No, he's literally writing get
baited. Like this guy is literally dancing on his corpse right
now. Sh- on him saying, hey, I'm literally a sh- I'm in here
to [__] you over. And he's literally just showboating
on Hasan [__] while he's trying to explain himself.
It's ironic because >> It's so easy to one guy him. Apparently
it is. Yes, I do actually. This is literally my area of expertise
when it comes to Dude, if you're saying this is my area of expertise
over a guy who's writing get baited on screen from your chat
that's highlighted to thousands and thousands and thousands of
people. Like this is so dumb. Um international
Is I don't know. It seems like a pretty
Dude, this is one of those things. I'm starting to realize that
no criticisms of streamers are true.
As I become like a As I stream more and more and more people
see my content and it gets like clipped and put on Twitter, I'm
starting to realize that no criticism of streamers is actually
real. It's all based on like what can I paint out of like four
different moments. So you stream or like basically
Imagine somebody took 0.01% of the things you say and built like
a a picture of you and presented that as you to the world, and
it was like effective, and they like had tons of eyes on it,
right? That's what happens to like every streamer,
Is this is like one moment out of Hassan's stream out of like
a thousand chat interactions. This happens like one or two times.
Maybe even more, but maybe it's like one out of 100. Right? Where
somebody's just like oh, I got you. You paid it. Right? It's
It's just crazy that people Nicholas is now going to do some
analysis this when it's like actually the thing that Hassan's
bread and It's like Hassan's bread and butter for his stream.
When he When he got no content in a day, he'll just yell at random
chatters.
YOU ARE JUST A TRANS PERSON, OKAY?
But But now Nick is like, well, you shouldn't do this at all.
This is like really bad for you, actually. This is like horrible
for you. Do you realize how bad this is? You're like You're like
paying attention to these people? Nick, of course, being a whiny
cowardly [__] who when he gets criticism just bans
people, just bans entire topics from his chat, right?
Actually, Hassan, you don't understand. You should be a whi-
whiny cowardly like me. That's what you should do, Hassan. Be
a wired wha- Be a cowardly loser like me.
A whiny cowardly loser. That's what you should do. >> questions
when it comes to uh like talking about anti-imperialism,
not only do I have a degree in just this, but also on top of
that, I I've spent the last decade or so talking about exactly
this scenario. So no, uh in in comparison to the average comment
>> Bro, a decade of rambling on stream does not make you
an expert in anything. And I'm not I don't I don't think he would
I don't know. I don't think expert is really the word, but it
doesn't really even make you necessarily informed on everything.
commentator in the United States of America.
What about the university degree? I Is his degree not in literally
international relations?
Is that not I could have sworn. Oh, he has a Yeah, he says it
at the begin- at the end. Like I have a degree. He has a degree,
and he talks about it every day. You'd think that gives you like
the depth and then the ability to build on that depth,
America, both to my right and uh you know, the liberal content
creators as well, I do have uh the the specific knowledge to
communicate about >> A political science degree has
Foreign policy, international relations, these are like Well,
Yeah, I think those are slightly different, right? Yeah, those
are different. International relations is a like a subdiscipline,
a sub like specialty of a poly sci degree, if I remember correctly.
No? >> I've watched BreadTube Guys, Innuendo >> Undergrad? Yeah,
I think so. >> have been making content for
seven years. Oh, well, maybe he's just the bad one, okay?
>> Let that sink in. This guy's entire livelihood I thought
that was the whole point of a poly sci agree with you actually
focused and you got like a thing but was on a channel that was
losing money for 7 years and he didn't become an expert in anything.
events >> He wasn't even any good at it. >> such
as this one analyze them interpret them and educate the public
on them.
on the other hand you can yeah I mean chat rent free holy baited
law. It basically goes to show exactly what you're trying to
get out of this. But Dude what you were trying TO GET LAW LAW
LAW LAW. Yeah on contrary to your favorite content creator I
do have a degree in just this right this is what I
>> it's disputed he doesn't have does he have a poll degree?
And this is
Did not what?
How do you wait how do you spend all this time covering Hassan
and you don't know what his degree is in at all?
He literally has a special avatar with the Ethan Hassan destiny
spaghetti that he's serving up again for the thousandth time
that he's reheating.
And he doesn't even know. >> What I've been doing for the
past 10 years which is precise. >> someone corrected him
on yeah. Hassan [__] graduated laude from Rutgers
with a bachelor's degree holding a dual degree double major in
political science and communication studies. So I guess poll
science. So not international relations.
I see Would that not be encompassed in political science? The
reason why my analysis so far has been
Oh Crowder called you a commie cosplayer today so these people
were told what to think about you today. Oh Oh my God. >> Is that
what it is? >> By the way Crowder is literally a cosplayer
too so I really don't know if you can take that criticism from
him.
Yes Steven Crowder is a great example of What what does Nicholas
think like all political pundits are? Like do you think the people
on CNN spend a ton of time crafting policy? Not often.
A ton of the people are just entertaining and they talk about
politics. They have like a knowledge. That's what it takes to
be a political >> person who is not very knowledgeable
Dude also can we just can we just somebody link me the tweet
of him being like I just really hope Destiny can put another
panel on like the January 6th one so I can learn about like the
tenant media scandal cuz you know what I would rather it's way
more important that somebody be a failed music major than have
an actual degree in political science. That's who's that's who
I listen to.
It's so fake he's so fake this isn't a standard he has at all.
>> but simply regurgitates American >> do you really
want to put yourself next to Steven Crowder?
These guys are just cosplayers. Bro you And by the way I would
never say Destiny has no expertise cuz he spent 10 years arguing
this stuff publicly. Like that is a level of expertise you do
learn the
Like obviously why what does he think?
Dude I don't know what it what does he want? Does he want like
only politicians to speak on this stuff or cuz you'd think like
10 years as a pundit 8 years as a pundit that's a lot of experience
real world experience. I mean like I guess maybe you could win
some yardage there but does that really make do you look good
if you own Steven Crowder in 2026?
I
feel like >> that's not really as much of a win as it would
have been like a decade ago. >> appreciated the shoutout
Right? I don't >> Hassan has a degree in master debating.
He likes to master debate on stream all day and all night. Enterprise
Institute talking points for example this He's like oh thank
God somebody bailed me out of this rant that I've been I was
literally sinking in with Steven Crowder. >> Like one great
example he's a bad person overall and not very knowledgeable
on these issues as well they're just you know repeating whatever
kind of
they're repeating whatever kind of talking points they're getting
from >> Thank you. Mr. Israeli think tanks. Dude it's unironically
like the laziest [__] I've ever seen in my life.
It's just so insanely lazy.
He he says Israel
and immediately juice juice juice juice juice he's complaining
about juice
This is this is JN. Contrary to most people's belief okay JN
not exclusively an illness that affects people of ethnicity okay.
JN can affect the white the black every color under the sun
kind of the guy
they're repeating whatever kind of talking points they're getting
from >> Thank you. you know Israeli think tanks. I do think
we're going to skip to the Cuba coverage okay I don't I don't
want to go back to this we're going to keep it focused keep it
tight on the Cuba coverage okay. Hassan explains the difference
between my oh now we're in Cuba by the way you can tell by his
Hawaiian shirt. Cubans best people so I don't want to read the
quote we're going to hear him talk about it. Cubans Like you
know how you know his fun China trip that nobody talked about
and only really spoke negatively about when he got back this
is the Cuban trip and it's going to probably be similar. Cubans
[__] best people okay. If we're talking about cigars
then I have to agree.
We're talking about people obviously. so >> it. just the
best
just the absolute
best people Oh my lord. Okay anyway but yeah we we worked hard
and we were able to we were >> Does he speak Spanish? Bro
why would he need that [__] dude he's got his biceps
could talk for him. We're about to set up a
What? What? Why do we throw that one out there Nick? That's a
little wait what? Nick Nick brings up that what was it the Vanity
Fair article where Hassan's in the the tub? Nick be pulling that
[__] up all the time to remind himself that he hates
this guy. I [__] hate this guy [__] hate
it. He's bringing that picture up a lot okay. Why would he why
would he even need to speak Spanish? His biceps speak for him.
We're about to set up a goddamn stream you know. [snorts] Not
in Miami. Oh dude it's the reversal.
actually like the exact opposite >> Oh what you're going
to see here is he said that he wouldn't use Elon Musk Starlink
to stream and people are speculating that he is but part of the
funny aspects of the Cuba [__] is that his stream
is just suffering from like horrific frame dropping to the point
where like really funny [__] like this happens that's
been like a that's a that's a whole aspect to the clips you're
going to see from here. Like all the good Cubans stay here. Listen
he lied about using Starlink he's using Starlink and even if
he's not using Starlink we get to laugh at communists.
Wait is it is it Starlink that's failing? Or is it communist
internet that's failing?
Which what is failing here exactly?
It's like he is both lying about using Starlink and using the
communist internet that is failing him. I said like what?
and most of the I just saw him pause it. He used the cloak of
invisibility all the good Cubans stay here where is here nowhere.
most of the ones >> He's completely gone dude. that are
crazy just like blew up there. Dude only the bad Cubans make
it to America all the good ones just love living in Cuba. for
God >> That's not that's not necessarily true but the ones
that didn't support that weren't a part of the revolution the
ones who had the property were the people who fled right? fled
the people who fled. They like It is true that if you were like
a wealthy person in Cuba who was not on the side of the revolution
at all you left Cuba cuz you would have been
So a ton of the diaspora that is the way it leans obviously.
Why would we why are we just saying things that like
Why do you doubt things that would just obviously be true?
I by the way I'm not even going to I don't even need to talk
to those people
I'm just saying it's obviously true that the people who left
were not friends or fans of the regime. I had really Oh my God
dude and an LGBTQ flag spawned on the screen yeah. funny experience
Dude look look at how progressive Hassan is he's got like the
he's got the entire LGBT
flag here dude it's even got like the uh
the the baby blue and pink for trans people. It's like we >> Why
is it lagging dude it Never mind go back go back to doing the
same like 12 jokes man this is not your improv not his strong
suit. >> equality that you're that you've come to expect
in Cuba. Get in the car we get in the we get into Uber last night
March and I were about to discuss
that we're going to be flying to Cuba like talking about plans
And I was like March don't say anything. Cuz I noticed
that the dude in the car
was a Miami Cuban and I was like don't
Like I literally >> Dude just stop don't say any crazy
racist [__] about Miami Cubans dude we literally
got one of the car.
Don't say anything. And then I just asked him. Was he listening
to the
He was saying don't talk about who we're meeting or what we're
doing there. No dude. I was like where you from? And he's like
oh Cuba and I was like okay. And I just asked him about like
you know what his feelings are about what's going on March actually
spat some some Spanish at him okay.
and let me tell you okay.
He said Donald Trump
needs to finish the job.
So he found like a very anti Cuba Cuban okay. That's what he
said that was the first guy and this is like
That yes that's that's a most of the most of the older population
who are Cuban in Miami would be anti Cuba. Yes this is just a
well understood thing. Nick is straight up Nick is out here being
like the performative anti racist who's like why would never
assume that you hold an opinion that 95% of the people in the
region who look like you hold. That's like actually wrong to
do to assume that this Miami Cuban would would think this. Oh
well never mind he did actually hate Cuba.
Okay good one. I guess this was March's first real interaction
with like a Miami Cuban, you know what I
This was his first ever interaction with a real Miami Cuban,
like a real ass Miami Cuban, right? So, he was like kind of shocked.
Why is he doing accents, guys? Remember, accents are okay.
Actually, if Hasan [__] just did an accent right
here, I feel like I can do them Wait, I thought I thought Nick
told me Nick made me believe that Hasan fans don't let you do
accents. I thought Hasan fans were like, "No, all accents are
racist and wrong." Why does Hasan get to do all Hasan gets to
do all of these accents? Why does he get to do He's the master
disguise. He's out here doing every accent under the sun. But
Nick would have you believe that apparently all accents are bad.
It's crazy. Okay.
Actually, if Hasan [__] just did an accent right
here, I feel like I can do them in with impunity, right?
>> the rule. If Hasan [__] does like [__]
accents, I can do accents. Go ahead. I know I know what the sh-
Stop. Go ahead and do the accent. >> And back in standby
Asian people, Nick Di Oreo can do accents again. rematch look
like my I guarantee you he just does the he just does the Family
Guy the Family Guy Asian woman driver. That's his Asian accent,
100%, right? Good luck, everybody else. That's that's definitely
the Asian accent he has. >> I'm monitoring it. I'm monitoring
the situation and I'm monitoring the stream as well.
So, so March did not experience that at all. So, there was that
was like his first ever inclination. The guy had no family here.
They were all in Miami, right? So, like
you know, obviously he was uh he was the classic like, you know,
bomb it all. Dude, he was the classic like >> Like god
super anti-Cuban
person who's fled the country. assorted out type guy and then
>> Why do we like box people up in countries that we like
when they flee for like asylum or something? Like why are why
are It it depends on whether we like the country or not on how
we view those people. This morning we had another conversation,
but this guy was actually so-so on Trump and he was still >> Like
if people weren't sucking Iran like crazy like before the America
intervention war crap that's happening right now. Like we're
just talking about iDubbz making up 50 reasons why living in
Iran is awesome and cool. Like why do we sweep for Iran, but
we also have to like die on the cross for Cuba?
I literally don't understand anything he just said. What is he
What is he talking about? Dude, I Did I have a stroke? He just
said something totally nonsensical. I think I had a stroke. Well,
then I have to go back and listen to everything he just said
again.
Cuz I None of that made any sense. Literally, none of that made
sense. >> was uh he was the classic like, you know, bomb
it all. Dude, he was the classic like Like god super anti-Cuban
person who's fled the country. assorted out type guy Yes.
And then Why do we like box people up
Yeah, wait, yes.
Does he not believe that a lot of people who left Cuba, who fled
Cuba don't like the regime and want it taken over militarily
or in any way possible?
Does he not understand?
in countries that we like when they flee for like asylum or something?
Like why are why are It it depends on whether we like the country
or not on how we view those people. This morning we had another
conversation, but this guy was actually Is he tr- Okay. >> so-so
on Trump
Is he trying to say that if you flee a good country, you like
the diaspora who fled a country you like? Well, usually if you
like the country one would assume that there's not diaspora who
are like refugees. And he was still like >> Like if people
weren't sucking Iran like crazy like before the America intervention
war crap that's happening right now. Like we're just talking
about iDubbz making up 50 reasons why living in Iran is awesome
and cool. Like why do we sweep for Iran, but we also have to
like die on the cross for Cuba?
I don't know. It just seems like location Dude, he's so lost.
Sucking Iran? I've no idea what he's talking about. He said iDubbz
like made up reasons why living in Iran would be good. Maybe
that happened. I've no idea. I have no idea where the rest of
this analysis coming from, though. He's He's somehow Like even
if you're going to do paint by
right-winger analysis you would just say "Oh, look, communist
regime and Islamic regime, these guys love anybody who hates
America."
That's the analysis. Why are you trying to do something more
complicated than that, Nick? That's the Just do the analysis.
Serve up the same rerun for the 1,100th night in a row, okay?
Stop trying to think. Stop trying to make this complicated. It's
not complicated. It's super simple.
>> we like, here's our dialogue tree. Location we don't
like, here's our dialogue tree. The no new
I He
This doesn't work. >> wants to do it at all whatsoever.
Like, oh, the government is like stealing everything. It's bad.
But he's saying Hasan hates Iran? I guess so. I guess he's saying
Hasan hates Iran.
I guess.
He's like retar- He's [__] the analysis anyway.
Right? He should be arguing if he wants to argue the the the
same points, he should say "Well, actually, Hasan loves Iran.
So, he hates the Sorry. But then under Nick's lens, he'd have
to love the diaspora from Iran. But he does not. Everybody hates
the diaspora from Iran, okay? Well, at least with regards to
this conflict. Persian people are okay. And blah blah blah communism
is bad.
But he was a little bit more open-minded cuz I was able to like
talk to him about the embargo. You know, they have this very
weird attitude about it.
They have this very weird attitude about it. Why is he in Cuba?
It's the exact same thing as like why he was in China. It's a
propaganda tour.
No, it's not. No, it's not. There's no way this guy is this stupid.
Seriously? It's not the same at all.
Dude, it's an aid It's an aid thing. They're taking aid to a
country under blockade. Even if you didn't know that, it's an
aid thing. How do you miss that through all of this that they're
trying to take aid to this country and bring awareness to the
blockade that's
What was he There's nothing like that when he goes to China.
Look how cool Cuba is, guys. The one streaming from there right
now and they haven't killed me. Or something, I don't know. And
they kind of know Dude, there's no way he's this lazy. [snorts]
This is actually the the laziest Nicholas Di Oreo segment I've
ever seen.
Dude, these people aren't even trying
Bro, he just comes in and he's like He's just like China. It's
like Dude, I'm in Cuba and they didn't even kill me. And this
is why you should actually understand the politics before you
talk cuz if you don't if you don't understand anything going
on. And I'm not even saying you have to agree. You could say
Like if Nick showed up here and he was like a He was a part of
the sugar mob, okay? And from Florida, he got a big bag from
the sugar mob and he was like, "Actually, these communists killed
everybody. They killed children. It didn't even matter. And and
they took like our lands and we just want the the people to be
free. And we're going to go back as the former sugar plantation
owners and we're going to build a awesome democratic capitalist
economy there." If he was at least doing coherent propaganda
I would be like, "Okay, well, you did your homework. You know
you're playing a side of this. At least there's something reasonable
happening here." But he's totally incoherent. He's totally lost.
He's just running purely on Hasan is bad after kind of calling
it out before. Dude, what did he call out before? What did he
call out on the Hasan is bad thing? I can't remember. What did
he call out when he was like, "Oh, maybe this Oh! It was Think
Before You Sleep doing the
the Hasan conspiracy. At least that was creative.
At least Think Before You Sleep made some [__] up.
At least he tried to do something.
Like I It was totally It was totally re- But at least it wasn't
and lazy.
You're hitting even You're hitting even lower depths than Think
Before You Sleep right now. Nobody is censoring my stream. I
love the I love the Cuban state. They understand what their what
their families' lives looked like or felt like when there was
a little bit of sanctions relief and like they could send money
with ease to their Dude, you want to know the crazy thing? The
person who gave me these timestamps for this stream just messaged
me and was like, "Actually, just so you know, the Di Oreo stream
from tonight is even worse. It's
It's even worse. And I just don't know how that's possible. I
can't see how that's possible. their families, you know what
I mean? Like
It's just such a strange cognitive dissonance to experience in
real time, but you know, I gave a couple interviews on the at
the airport and stuff and then we flew in.
Dude, all right, moving forward. Uh now we're going to start
getting into the the struggle to stream quote unquote not using
Elon Starlink. Tommy told me cuz Tommy C used Elon Starlink for
a little while while he's getting his internet set up that it
would be extremely
Oh, I didn't think about this angle. That he's getting totally
flopped by Gwain and Harley going totally ape [__]
on Hasan. And so, he needs to get back on the ball, okay? Hasan
is bad. Hasan is bad. Hasan is bad. Because if you guys haven't
seen listen that audience after an hour, they they'd rendered
their decision, okay, guys? They'd rendered their decision once
and for all and they overwhelmingly
choose the Harley Gwain podcast over Nicholas Di Oreo, okay?
Two to one. Two to one.
All right? So, he's got to get back on side. Hasan is bad. Hasan
is evil. Nicholas, if you're going to sell your soul, at least
do some work, buddy, okay?
Don't sell your soul for cheap. Don't don't phone it in, okay?
Cuz there's nothing worse. All right? If If sell your soul, you
you kill off this other podcast, you take all their viewers or
something, then at least you won. Don't sell your soul and lose,
okay?
Show up with the Come correct to the stream, man. >> Spotted
it with Dropout and kind of similar to what he's saying here,
but again, it's disputed. I don't know what he's using there.
So Ethan took his time slot. Well, Ethan doesn't show up to that
show. It's just Qiam and Harley, but yes.
>> All right, why is this audio so bad?
It like that has nothing to do with
Even [laughter] a freaking
>> Even a freaking Dude, look at his chat right now. It
would have been an awesome
This is actually as coherent as the average Hasan stream. Oh,
I see. No, no, no, it does make sense. It does make sense. This
person is saying, "Oh, well, he won't use Starlink, so communist
internet totally him." That's what this person is saying, okay?
They're trying to do some Hasan is very bad clips.
I do think he's using Starlink, though. I think I understand
Starlink's illegal, somebody said that.
Although Starlink near the equator
that might also be quite bad.
I go back and forth. Cuz it seemed to me like it just crashed
on my end. Last time Hasan had internet, he was he obliterated
his dog. Who knows what other atrocities he will commit this
Thankfully, his dog is far away. Oh, cool, there's my Streamlabs.
Let me pull this back over. If I could drag it, got it, cool.
Uh I just got to restart Streamlabs and that should fix it. Boom.
Dude, that's so funny. Hasan is now fighting with a chatter about
the internet quality. No, stop. No, stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop.
I saw I saw Chud clip about this of Chud just like raging out
about how this person is like clearly just transparently trying
to do Hasan bad.
I'm just I'm just saying Nick should understand what where he
is in the world right now, okay?
You're watching you're you're literally using Leya Sapiante,
okay? Leya something as your source for information right now,
Nick.
Think about that. Think about Nick. Nick, think about it.
You know what that means? Reinforcing his long-running scheme
>> Stop. Dude, this guy has literally got the LGBTQ flag
on. Holy sh America carries too much of the burden within NATO.
And then thirdly, there is a domestic aspect to it as well. He
wants voters here in the United States to hear the message
I'm literally
this clip. dated March 19th, the day before Hasan [__]
here streaming from Cuba, Hasan stated he will not be using Elon
Musk's >> for other politicians. You can tell that he's
out of America, not because of his backdrop, which would be also
in America, because he's not like stuttering and the American
flag is not popped over him or like the trans flag is not popped
up. I saw So they're trying to do Hasan is bad, Cuban internet
sucks, communist internet sucks. Okay, got it. Activists, advocates,
journalists
on a humanitarian aid mission. I'm going to Cuba to one, bring
awareness to the plight of the Cuban population
as a direct consequence of American intervention on the island
nation for
the the last
couple of decades.
And I'm also going to deliver, alongside many others, humanitarian
aid to the Cuban population including >> Dude, he's going
to be delivering he's personally delivering humanitarian aid.
I can't wait to find out what that I mean, he literally just
said amongst many others.
He quite literally just said amongst others with like a He implied
it was like a big group of people, which it was. Hasan's Kefuls
tweet. Holy sh dude.
Oh, so you're personally doing No, that's not what he said. >> This
guy he's on an AIDS mission right now. He's Hasan [__]
is delivering aid to Cuba. >> is only good if you live
in a place they physically cannot get a cable. So I get like
900 megabytes a second, Starlink is like 10 megabytes max. Also
re That's a totally chatter. Starlink is a revelation. 10 megabytes
max is insane. I've never seen that before. Although,
Wait, that might be a problem. I think Starlink actually get
bandwidth constrictions if they've oversaturated an area. And
where I use Starlink is like there's nobody out there. So actually,
maybe it is maybe it is bad. I don't know, possibly. Possibly.
Really funny Hasan. Didn't Dude, where I where I am, bro, it's
It's nuts how good the Starlink stuff
I don't know, it's like it's crazy how good it is compared to
anything else. >> have the balls to Representative Castro
in front of Miami [laughter] It's It's enough that I like defended
Elon way longer than I should have, okay? It It changed like
my my cabin experience when it's like raining or ugly out. It
revolutionized it, okay? I could suddenly do Netflix, I could
play games, I could do anything versus like having no bandwidth
and no speed
Oh, it's crazy. >> including but not limited to solar panels.
$400,000
worth of solar panels have been bought by the Answer Coalition
and Code
We are going to get to the island and interview a bunch of people.
I'm going to be doing my regular news Has any of this happened
so far? Or I mean, this is
Well, I mean, this is before, right? March 19th. It's only been
a few days, so we haven't seen the the full length of the trip
yet, but >> coverage when I'm out there. As I mean, the
aid was delivered. We saw the aid pulling up. I have >> all
fake? I mean, I wouldn't say it's fake just yet, it would be
a little early to say that, cuz he's only been there for like
3 days. I've established a place where I'll hopefully be able
to have internet access and energy even though the grid is Like
these people are genuinely so convinced that Hasan is evil that
they think the most likely outcome is that Hasan is faking a
charity trip, like an aid trip to an island just for optics,
just to look good. They They actually think that. That's how
crazy the derangement has gotten. They think he's like faked
this whole thing with all these groups. Bro, Jeremy Corbyn is
there.
>> Like like it's Not not that I mean, maybe
maybe British people don't think Corbyn has like any credentials
or something. But it's like these are people who actually care
about the issue.
Like truly, there's a bunch of people going. The There were a
bunch of boats that pulled up with aid. Yes. It's not fake. >> is
on shaky grounds. Well, you know, the situation is very fluid
down there, but um
you know, I'm I'm very excited. I'm very excited to go to Cuba
and see He sounds so excited, by the way. It seems like He seems
ecstatic to go on this journey. to see the Cuban folks, which
is a beacon of hope and resilience.
So it's another propaganda mission. He keeps doing this. Dude,
I just love every clip of Hasan looking horrible. I I want to
pull this up quickly cuz it's like a new clip. This is from Yeet,
Hasan talking about what he did after his first broadcast. Dude,
it's actually so transparent now. Thank you, Basuto, for pointing
this out. It's so obvious that he's worried about the viewership.
He's just worried about having to compete with these people who
are going to go on and they're going to say the the ro
robotic talking points. Hasan is bad. Hasan is bad. And he knows
that he's going to lose everybody if he doesn't do
I Guys, I just love Show me all the Hasan is bad clips. Oh my
god. Oh my god. Guys, guys, this is so cool. Show me all the
clips. No, don't show me any articles or anything about who organized
this or or what aid is being sent. Don't show me No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. Just show me the clips of Hasan. I just
want the Hasan clips.
Dude, can we compare it to the Qiam coverage? Oh, best believe
we'll be comparing it to the Qiam coverage. Best believe I got
a bunch of clips of the Qiam coverage courtesy of Cathy. Cathy
sent these, okay? Yeah, we do. We got a bunch of clips. >> Hasan
could give us a bit more information on how his human his humanitarian
aid has been progressing.
Last night we ended the broadcast. >> Nicholas the goat.
And I went and linked up with the Progressive International boys.
I met Jeremy Corbyn. That was fantastic.
Uh and and I hung out with the Nica boys. We went out and and
and drank at like a local
>> no way, bro. Dude, Prapro Politics went to Cuba to go
drink in the pub. Okay.
This is all networking of every type. This is something that
somebody could only say if they have no experience in anything
but an entry-level job.
Literally all networking happens at some point over drinks. You
go to a restaurant, you go out get a drink, get a meal, okay?
You sit down, you talk, you do some pleasantries, and you get
down to business, okay? The It's so crazy that you could say
this.
You had a drink? You went over to a bar? Prapro Politics. Prapro
Politics, guys.
Yeah, Jeremy Corbyn, massive Prapro, I guess. Although, I actually
don't know very much about his reputation. I just know he's like
the leader of the I think the Labour Party in Britain for like
a long time, right?
Yeah. I don't He Maybe he's famous for partying or something.
I don't know. Dude, it's not just Japanese business deals. All
like networking you do, if you're at some event, if you travel
for an event, you will eventually go for drinks with the people
you're networking
It's what everybody does. You don't have to get drunk, but like
you go and you have a drink, you sit down, you chill. It's crazy.
>> Stream over, let's go drink in the pub. Maybe some humanitarian
sh happened
We have been
like we've just been living la vida
honestly. We've just been living life, living large.
you know, just peppering
people with with just wads of cash for the most part. Is that
it? They're just walking around just giving money to people on
the side of the road? With hopes that Okay, he didn't make it
quite as bad as what more Pegasus No, no, no. Who do we watch
that really blew this
Hasan [__] maybe? No.
I don't remember now. Who was the person who compared it to RiceGum?
That was particularly egregious. Was that Hasan [__]
Oh, I didn't realize. Okay. You're just peppering people with
wads of cash. There has to be a better way. It's like a little
We're just arming every person Guys, if you just happen to be
like tangentially close to
Has Nick never gone on like vacation to one of these countries?
They do They do appreciate tips in American dollars. You're supposed
to go take American cash out so you can pay people, right? That's
literally how it works, man.
What are we doing? economic respite This is spring break for
politics, yeah. But for each individual
He's just throwing wads of money at people. This is the only
way we can make it work. Cuban that we encounter.
A lot of the info that you hear and see from the island is like
directly coming from like most of the time like national people
will say crazy [__] like this all the time.
This is some like Mr. Beast video [__] They're just
not filming it. We just went to Cuba WITH $50 MILLION AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE GIVING it to the first people who walk up to us while
we're drinking at the pub tonight. I'm Mr. Beast and we're going
to Dude, yeah, this is literally I'm sorry. It's a Mr. Beast
video. Endowment for Democracy Foundation backed
individuals, you know, State Department propaganda and things
like that. But
Wait, he's like halfway to GETTING IT. OH MY GOD, HE'S HALFWAY
TO GETTING it though. Hold on. Mr. Beast does charity. I guarantee
you can find a bunch of tweets of Nick talking about how people
freak out at Mr. Beast when he actually helps people. 100% right?
Like oh, why do people treat Jimmy like he's so bad just cuz
he films it on camera? Like he is helping people. Are those people
not helped? Did those African villages not get wells? Dude.
Obviously, Mr. Beast is not evil. And if you're doing it off
camera, that's like even better. You're doing it without actually
doing it for for views, for clout. THAT'S JUST CHARITY. DUDE,
how I thought it was turning. These people are like These people
responded to us laughing at them and saying oh, the Hasan derangement
is turning. The Hasan is bad stuff is turning. They responded
by becoming significantly more deranged. Dude, it's wild.
In any case,
We pull up Dior's coverage of Mr. Beast African well situation.
Did he say that was ridiculous because he did do charity? I'm
positive he would have done this, right?
Yeah, I'm positive that he would have done this. I don't have
the Somebody Somebody wants to go find it real quick, but I'm
positive that Dior would have run defense for that. Um I Like
Mr. Beast main channel, not Mr. Beast like find philanthropy
where he like builds
Oh, he's like irrigation systems for Africa. I'm overcome Try
to rescue it? Oh, what were they delivering? Like solar panels?
Like life-saving energy aid to this country?
Ways to generate electricity for their hospitals and stuff? >> with
emotion. He's actually so right now. He's actually so right.
If he done any research, he wouldn't be saying half of these
totally things. It's actually crazy. at the beauty of this island
and the beauty of the It's It's incredible. It's It's truly one
of my favorite places officially. I totally understand why Will
was saying that about Cuba.
It's remarkable. The people's resilience is remarkable. There's
I mean, there's like rolling blackouts that take place throughout
the day every day all around the country, right? 11 million people.
But today is a beautiful day out here
75 degrees, sunny.
People are partying. People are partying in the streets. They're
I don't know if it's like a island mindset. I don't know if it's
like I don't know if that has something to do with it. partying
because you keep throwing money at them like [__]
content strippers? Like what's happening? I'm sure that has something
to do with it, but like
They're just chilling. Like a Cuban They're probably like partying
cuz there's literally nothing else to do. You can't watch TV,
you can't be playing video games. You probably just go out and
have a drink with your neighbors and like chill, right? I would
imagine it's beautiful weather outside.
That's just the best thing to do. It's just they they vibe. They
chill. Sounds like a really fun day to go out and cuz he can't
IRL stream. >> Dude, he went to a country where he literally
probably can't IRL stream. I'm just connecting this right now.
How would he He can't stream from his room with all the [__]
solar panels and [__] right? They just literally
Like whatever the [__] internet he's using here.
Vibe, it don't matter.
He probably can't go and film any of this reasonably.
Like it's it's incredible.
Yeah, there's like festivals every everywhere like all around
He flew to a country to tell us about how cool it is in a country
and then says he can't I don't know. He He's not saying directly
that he can't, but he reasonably can't show us this. That's very
funny. All right, now Cubans in Miami versus Cubans are complete
opposites. Cubans [__] best people. He already reacted
to this clip. How long is it going to take him to realize that
he already reacted to this
What do you guys think? Roundabout how long before he realizes
I've reacted to this exact clip already. Okay, so kind, so welcoming.
I think this might be the clip we already saw. So he's Okay,
oh. Okay, he's a little locked in. Okay. Oh, dude, I was about
to I was about to lose it. Nicholas the goat, thank you for the
$5, my man.
in the car Yeah, we saw this one. Moving up. Day two of Hasan
[__] in Cuba besides streaming from his hotel room.
Oh, is this one we just saw? Did we just watch this? Nicholas
Dior streamed about this last night and after watching Nick's
stream, I'm kind of like pill done this [__] Hasan
being in Cuba while they're having power issues sounds like a
bold strategy. Let's see how this plays out. He brews. Thank
you.
That's [laughter] a dog shocking joke, Nick. This leaning into
all the jokes about him being like Raiden and shocking his dog.
Interviews, drinking at bars, handing out cash. Um wow. Roach
is out from IRL streaming in cuz he ran into real Cubans that
don't want him there. Doesn't feel safe around Cubans. I don't
think he said those last two. Nicholas
the goat. Thank you for the $5, my man. Uh-oh. That's minus 500
viewers just left and went to Guam, okay? Cuz Guam was like that's
right. That's right.
Hasan is bad. Minus 500 viewers. Uh-oh. I don't know if that
has something to do with it. I'm sure that has something to do
with it, but like
They're just chilling. I know.
Do we have any real indication here? Like he found out eventually
that it was an aid trip and then he said it was just like the
China thing. What order did that go in? Where he like finds out
about the aid
Oh, no, it's it's basically in response. So he finds out He's
basically saying it's just like the China thing. And then he
finds out it's an aid trip. Okay. Now, is he going to come back
tonight and he's going to be more locked in? What do you guys
think?
I don't know.
Dude, it's one of the biggest clips.
Fine, hold on. We'll watch We'll watch his reaction to this clip.
Oh, you're saying why doesn't he have it? I see. I see. I see.
The government has very limited
And the American government make Oh, I have not heard either,
but I listen, I didn't have the YouTube transcript for this or
anything. I've not heard him talk about the actual blockade happening
either. So, we'll see if that works its way into the analysis
at all. I am just looking at timestamps, so I can't say for sure.
I haven't seen it during the clips, but we'll see if we see it
at any point. If you don't know that there's an aid mission happening
though, you got to figure he also doesn't know about it being
a blockaded and why there's rolling blackouts, right? Makes it
for Americans to stay wherever they want when they're in Cuba.
They have to stay in what they've declared as five-star hotels,
right?
I'm telling you all this because like even the five-star hotels
are not like, you know, They're It's not like this what the American
government has declared five-star hotels. Bro, they're like three-star
hotels at best, okay? Cuban hotels, they're they're still worse.
But regardless, in comparison There was a cut in the clip. I
don't think it's really significant. comparison to the situation
This isn't like the most damning clip of my life. I kind of see
what he's saying. He's saying that what Americans would deem
five stars is likely not translating to exactly five stars in
actual in Cuba. situation on the island. It's He's saying that
Cuba is like a totally like
I don't want to say a [__] country, but the standard
of like five stars in Cuba is not five stars in America. I think
is what he's trying to argue and I could believe that that's
probably accurate.
Like it's Oh, showing charity. Showing charity to Hasan. Uh-oh.
Minus 200 concurrents.
Minus 200 concurrents immediately. charity pretty much. Well,
you If I were to ever if I I mean, not ever I'll be back and
when I do, I'll probably If I ever come back, oh my god, bro.
What are they saying on the H3 sub? Thank you, grape tape. I
was saying something yet. Tourism is the life Poor baby has PTSD
after seeing the pores out his government mandated five-star
hotel. That's funny. The It's Dude. Dude, he's his soul is like
Oh my god.
Dude, I can just imagine.
His soul is just like rending.
That's funny. Poor baby has PTSD. That's
uh his government mandated five-star hotel. That's funny. The
That's funny. >> Dichotomy definitely me up. Sips room
service Oh my That is kind of true. He's sipping room service
espresso. He's getting He's getting his talking points from the
wine moms in the H3 subreddit. That's where he's getting his
jokes
That's funny.
Don't worry, guys. Seeing the dichotomy is really [__]
him up. [snorts] It's almost more scary than actually living
like a Cuban.
Honestly, what's the point? He's on the level of Trump where
he can just say whatever he wants and his fans will take it at
face value. It's clearly he's only staying in a nice hotel because
Well, I don't know. I'm not Dude, it would be easily checkable
to find out what resorts or hotels that Like if he's lying here,
then it'll get caught immediately. I'm going to take his word
for it cuz that's so stupid that I wouldn't believe. Like I He
would have to be brain dead to say something like that cuz I
would be Googleable.
It seems like the US government isn't mandating your stay at
five-star hotels.
Yeah, I I don't know why he said this precisely. It is a little
>> can't stand on a boat by or in part by the Cuban government.
So, it sounds disingenuous on his part. Are there any Are there
any three-star hotels that Yeah, he stayed at the same He did
stay at the same hotel as everyone else in the flotilla, yes.
>> by the government? Like the government will let you
stay at a three-star hotel? Like can you stay at like the equivalent
of a Knights Inn or something like a one-star hotel in Cuba?
There has to be.
But why why? Why would you do that?
I One, he is little He's sympathetic to the Cuban government.
So, I'm sure he would prefer to stay at a hotel that's run by
the Cuban government and pay whatever rent they're they're charging,
whatever nightly fees they're charging for the hotel to help
the regime, right? Like he literally wants to help them in any
way he can.
There's no reason Dude, this this like weird Dude, it's the poverty
cult thing all over again. It's so stupid, man. He is definitely
so goofy. Okay, I think we could go over to the Guam stuff real
quick, okay? I got sent a bunch of clips of the Guam stuff. Let's
just see a little bit of her flotilla coverage, okay?
Hold on. Am I going to get these in the right order? Okay. Let's
Let's check these out. These are just little clips from the Harley
and Guam podcast from tonight. Let's see how it compares,
We're looking at Speaking of state-sponsored media, let's check
in with correspondents
Guam and Harley Morenstein, okay? He
to there, posted up in like the sickest designer clothes, went
to a Niki concert at a bouncy next to everyone who's literally
and he streamed on Starlink
sipping espressos.
Dude,
That's That's awesome. Harley actually doing some work, okay?
Harley actually doing some work. He just rolls all the talking
points into one sentence. It's a run-on sentence, but hey, he's
at least aware a little bit of what's going on. Guam be like,
"Flotilla? You mean what they wrap burritos in?"
What the [__] is What the [__] was even
happening? Like What the [__] is even happening?
I mean, it's the same thing he did in China, right? He was in
this like insane hotel while >> But how do people eat this
[__] up? It's >> know. Like it's crazy cuz
It's probably the significant amount of medical and power-based
aid that was sent to the country. I'm guessing that's how most
people eat it up. Getting eyes on the issue with the most popular
people they can. I'm guessing it's some combination of these
factors that people are talking about it again as opposed to
it just going dark in the media, right? Nobody ever caring. Cuban
people like suffering with these blackouts with no voice, no
no ability to even broadcast what's going on, right? I'm guessing
cuz that's what's happening, >> happening, right? And I
understand. I'm not I'm saying, you know, if there was good that
came of this, great cuz there's a lot wrong with Cuba. And it's
not all America's fault. There's no ever There's never some black
and white
>> This is all America's fault. Actually, there might be
things wrong with Cuba. There might be things wrong with communist
management of the economy.
This current like this current crisis they're in is entirely
manufactured by America one to one.
Oh, don't worry, Smatak. When I read the comment, I knew it was
from I knew it was from Deep Aroma or Jimberly. I know. It's
fine. We We got to We got to give Qwiman credit for some things,
okay? I knew that that's who it originated from. Don't worry.
Possibly Stylo. They want They want there to be that. Yeah, they
want there to be that. But what he was doing like what is he
doing there? I leading up to it there was so much Yeah. Like
I thought he was like the Greta of this of this aid mission.
>> I'm going on the flotilla." I mean, I really thought
it was going to be a ship
going to Cuba the way that the ship went to God. Oh, I do think
Hasan basically said he was going to go on the flotilla and then
flew out. >> Which I totally understand. I wouldn't take
a [__] boat across that I wouldn't take like a sailboat
across that No way. But I do think he basically said he was going
to go on the flotilla, be a part of the flotilla, and then was
like, "Actually, I can just fly Yeah, I'll just fly in. Yeah,
I'll just fly in."
>> Gaza, which he also didn't do, even though he said he
was considering going to Gaza, as we all remember. >> And
he was paid for this? The Cuban government had reached out to
his team, >> I can't I have no idea.
Um I know that It was definitely a state-sanctioned trip if it
wasn't a state-sponsored trip. The Cuban government did like
go and and try to solicit people to come help, I I
Here's a clip of him saying that the Cuban government reached
out to him like 11 months ago. I don't know if it's about this,
but there was a press conference
run by the the foreign affair the Cuban foreign affairs department
ministry. Um so, there's definitely and there's like these tours
that that some of the people went on where they're like, "Wow,
everything's so wonderful here and you know, the health care
is amazing." It's like There are Wait, there are some advantages
to Cuba. If you're like somebody who's getting sick,
right? If you don't have like a cancer that's like deep in your,
you know, like in your pancreas or something, Cuba could be a
a better place to get sick in some cases for certain things.
Like just the it's They have more doctors. They just have more
doctors who are trained reasonably well. I think it's like one
thing, hey, communism's not going to lose in every single possible
way all the time, right? They are going to sometimes have like
things that And I think, you know, the propagation of medical
knowledge is one of the things. The literacy rate, stuff like
that. It's not I wouldn't make that trade-off personally, but
it's like you They They can't be bad in everything, like literally
every single thing. Okay. More clips as we go along, all right?
They got a breast cancer vaccine? I don't believe that, but okay.
I honestly don't even know if >> Hasan was at this concert.
Like I didn't see his content cuz I don't follow him. I follow
some of the other people that went. And I don't know if he was
even there. Like I didn't see the live >> like what happened?
What what was the thing? What was all this noise about? He just
streamed from the hotel room, like Well, and also >> you
know what? I've always said it to people cuz some people clown
the way he dresses. He He has a particular taste. And I'm not
fully against it, but it's very expensive. It is. >> And there's
this very interesting prison that he's created for himself because
I've met creators that are big on flexing. They love clothes,
cars, things like that. I've seen it for a long time. >> of
Yeah, compared to XQC who makes a comparable amount of money,
he's like barely spending anything, right?
I don't I think Listen, I think thousand-dollar shirts are cringe,
but if he was going to do, you know, like some rich person hobby,
at least he's not doing watches or supercars or some [__]
like that, right? I don't know. over a decade. I mean, I just
know he's one of those guys. And I It's It's almost comical that
he has to flex no matter what. Like he's there and he's got,
you know, he's got his outfits. Did a stylist
Did you bring your stylist to Cuba on the aid mission? But yeah,
but you're right. There is like he's created this very narrow
lane for himself. Is that a
that's not even a good dude. He probably picked the outfits out
before he went. >> Or he's also >> Like I don't know.
Dude, the best socialist, right? If he was just like a
a streamer,
and he was going to Cuba to
you know what I mean? I don't think people would be like, "Oh,
like pocket watching his whole outfit, finding out that his glasses
are like $1,300
and his shirt's like $700, right?" But he has been the one >> pocket
watching, though. What do you say? We've been pocket We've been
pocket watching. We'll We'll pocket watch him, of course. If
you put yourself on a pedestal like he has,
people are going to people are going to check you and make sure
that you're not a hypocrite. And to me, a lot of what he does
is very
I honestly don't You could say it's cringe. Why don't you say
it's cringe? It's not really a
It's just cringe. Just call it cringe. But they need like the
moral indictment, too, right? It's actually hypocritical. He's
actually such a [__] hypocritical loser. Just leave
that part
Just say it's cringe.
It's cringe that he like he he wants other people to give up,
you know, pay more in taxes, but he buys all the [__]
It doesn't even have to make sense. You just say it's cringe.
You find it cringe. So easy.
Okay, hold on. We got a little bit of Code Pink analysis, all
right? This is I just want to keep it all in line, okay? All
framed correctly. We are
>> Wait, no, I didn't see it. Where'd the bun go? Oh, Anisa
is winning. Anisa stays winning. Guam got rid of that
Turns out that [__] was moldy and it's gone. It's
gone. She had to wash her hair, okay? Ain't no more [__]
bun here. Okay, I I got to I just want to reframe this. We're
just watching the people who are taking all of Nik DeOro's viewers,
okay?
very cool stream. I'm guessing this has a lot to do with the
fact that you can actually hear them complete full sentences
without 85 TTS messages going
That's to be honest, this is more listenable to me. Not that
these people are funnier.
They're not funny, but at least it's like, you know, coherent
English and not getting interrupted every 5 seconds. But his
followers have decided that he gets
benefit of the doubt. He gets all the grace in the world, right?
He He can do no wrong. He's allowed to flex his wealth. He's
allowed to hoard his
Right? He's allowed to do all these things. He's allowed to do
like performative ineffectual
in Cuba cuz I didn't see him delivering aid, painting a mural,
doing anything like that. >> Well, that's what I'm talking
about. What happened? What was What was the thing? What did he
do there? >> there. He streamed. The internet was terrible
from what I saw.
And then he flew home. I mean, I think he was there for one full
day. Did he do
I don't know. Like I I did not see I did not see anything except
the streaming and the fact that he streamed for a day. >> I
don't I also don't watch, so I don't know what's going on. I'm
not filled in, but what it looked like was when I heard that
he left that he was there for a day. Yeah. I was like, wait,
what? I thought he was just getting started. I thought he was
there Well, yeah. I I don't know how long the trip is, but it's
definitely longer than a day because there were people doing
There were other people on the ground like doing things like
delivering
aid and and things like that. And and people painted a mural,
which like I don't think the people need a mural. But also, I'm
not going to say that art isn't a wonderful, beautiful, important
thing, right? I did Dude, I think >> see like a bunch of
the women in the Code Pink group. They went to like fix a swing
set.
the the metal poles of the swing set had been painted over so
many times. There were just like layers of paint. And so they're
like, we didn't know what to do.
So then the children told us to to sand it with rocks. So there's
these like 50-year-old women just like banging rocks on these
like metal poles. I'm like, why are Why are you doing?
What the [__] are you doing? Helping. What are you
doing? You You are helping >> What are you doing? Grab
a rock and bang
Imagine paying like such meticulous attention to all of the press
around this, any social media feed that's like putting anything
out about this, just so you can snark on the people who are bringing
aid to the country.
Like from the comfort of your home or studio. I'm not sure if
they're in the same studio or not. It looks like they're kind
of overlaid over each other, but dude, it's actually wild, right?
That's That's the whole thing here. They're actually just snarking
on like old ladies who brought a bunch of aid.
For what reason?
It's all this bad. That's the reason. on this metal.
Grab a rock or shut up. He's like, I cannot believe that this
is real. No, I really I don't I don't understand. I I thought
I don't know. I thought I was going to understand, but then it
was over and I was like, oh, that was weird.
I The only way you make this funny is by like actually snarking
on the people. And they're actually too to even do that. They're
just going to mock what these people are doing their their like
actions a little bit. They're too If you wanted to go and pull
up that video and talk about how empty and meaningless these
people's lives are that they're here hitting a swing. You want
to start like actually snarking, then by all means, okay?
But until you're ready to commit and actually be mean or entertaining
in some way, you guys should find something else to do. It's
very sad watching like these totally tepid, lukewarm takes. These
guys can't even be mean. >> If you just see this on the
internet, and I can't play the sound, obviously. But if you just
see this on the internet
you see people crowd surfing, you see this bouncy house
slide in the background. You see people
Anyway, so so this is also the message was also to bring awareness
to the fact that like hospitals don't have power >> Exactly.
[laughter]
>> Exactly.
Like there aren't enough generators, but most certainly this
concert was using generators, right? Like shows. >> Who's
this concert
Who's Who's this for?
They said it was it was a local festival, but
this is all
This is all like young white men. >> and and Hassan That's
like an old Cuban lady with a 7 Up or something.
Dude, it's Dude, it's like These are all like young white men,
okay? Bro, and they're not even attempting
They're not even attempting to like comment on any Dude, it's
totally disconnected. It's actually like North Korean propaganda.
Like it's This is the H3 equivalent of North Korean propaganda.
A lot of Cubans are white-skinned. Yeah, they might be like light-skinned,
but they're going to be living in Cuba, they're probably going
to be pretty tanned. Like this guy. Is this guy white? >> Do
we think this guy right here is white? I'm not totally sure.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Is a I love I love white women. I
love white women, okay?
But not white, not male. local festival This guy, I can't tell.
festival, but
this is all
This is all like young white men. No, this is like This is like
North Korean propaganda. Shut up, Bloobern. This is like North
Korean This is like
Kim Jong-un.
He shot the 12 holes in one today playing golf. What an incredible,
glorious leader.
It's just totally detached from reality.
It's very funny. >> And and and and Hassan didn't post
that he was there. No, no, no, no. But this was like other people
like Chris Smalls, who is the guy that um did some really great
organizing work uh for Amazon and got a lot of the people there
unionized. He posted a lot from this concert. So these These
are his some of the things. >> actually I think uh Hassan
Like you could see the dissonance. Oh, all these people who do
really good things are here like doing horrible things like killing
babies in hospitals by power outage.
Dude, it's it's so
Dude, this Glen person I seems like probably like a big Leftovers
fan, I'm guessing, right? Right? Like she seems to know a lot
about these people and how they organize what they're doing.
She would support it in any other case, but she got the call.
She got to go out. She got to hate. Big, huge, huge. Hassan is
smart enough, regardless, uh to know that this would be whack.
>> Yeah. [laughter] NO, NO, NO. HASSAN ACTUALLY, THIS IS
PROBABLY HASSAN sitting in his hotel
It's maybe something you could actually
Instead you're going to say, oh well, Hassan knew this is bad
optics, so he didn't go. Uh weird, right? Cuz I I don't know.
I don't know everything going on there, but I I know the hospitals
don't have power. >> got a dirt What the [__]
>> What the Yeah. >> I don't know everything going
on there, cuz I I don't know. I don't know everything going on
there, but I I know the hospitals don't have power, so this is
very bizarre. >> That's their team who Okay. >> people
at this time. He was interviewing people? Yeah, like interviewing
people that lived there. Talking to them about the conditions
and Like the thing he said he was going TO DO. BRO, THIS IS ACTUALLY
SO FUNNY. Uh Hassan was actually doing the thing he said he was
going to do. Going to go like talk to the locals. That's what
he was doing during this.
Dude, she's just like, oh well, uh Hey, [snorts] well, Okay,
that's what Golly's saying. Okay, maybe there's going to be like
a long-form thing he would he puts out or something like
>> I I just like watching, okay?
Watching people sell their souls very funny to me now. I just
It's just good. It's a good watch. It's a good watch every time.
There were just like some weird things. So there was this thing,
and then like a lot of the volunteers kept like taking pictures
with kids in the street.
Which felt
What is she implying there?
Actually, you know, all leftists are Guys, we all know this,
right? >> very like white Christian missionaries going
to Africa kind of treating treating it like a safari thing. >> Yeah,
I saw people saying like poverty safari and stuff like that.
I don't know. The optics The optics to me were not great. I have
no actual moral criticism, but I want to be very upset about
this. So I'm just going to whine about optics all day long. Optics,
optics, optics, optics.
Good one.
But it actually just looks bad.
there was a ton of Yeah, I don't doubt that it looks bad to people
who figure out every single possible way to analyze something
Hassan's involved in poorly. I It's not shocking to me, right?
It obviously that's going to happen. Obviously it looks bad to
you when everybody around you hates everything he's involved
in in any way.
of medical and other kinds of aid that were delivered via the
convoy
um from the US, from Italy, from from different countries, which
is a wonderful thing. Um I, of course, then have questions about
okay, well, how is that aid being distributed?
Because
some people say, oh, well, it's going to go through the government,
and then the government is going to profit off it by selling
it
to individuals, to hospitals.
Um but I don't know. I I don't know enough The government's going
to sell it to
Okay. I
I'm sure people track that. I'm sure someone's tracking [__]
like that.
The hospitals they own? Did she forget that it's a communist
country?
This is This is so funny. Guess what? Guess what happens in a
communist country? Not a whole lot of free
>> They're just going to sell it. They're just going to
sell it. Listen, they're going to sell it in those those wealthy
hospital owners, also the
>> They're going to pay for solar panels for dying people.
Like, dude, how hard are you trying right now?
Dude, I didn't realize how bad this was. I thought this was going
to be 2 minutes quick review of Guaman Harley. Oh, this is rough
improv. They're like trying to figure out criticisms on the fly.
of about the insides of Only capitalist would do [__]
like that. But it DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING JEFF BEZOS sold a loader from one Amazon warehouse
to another Amazon warehouse.
Jeff Bezos owns all of the Amazon
It doesn't make any [__] sense.
Yeah, I took that I took that at complete face value. It might
not be accurate. I'm like, okay, so they brought millions of
dollars of critical aid there. That is cool. I know of some creators
that did take a boat there. I'm aware of that. If that is good
if there is something positive that can happen about that,
that's cool. I'm just sick of Hasan's [__] Yeah,
me too. >> On this day we're Hey, hey, at least Harley
knows where his bread is buttered, okay? Listen, I know there's
some good work going on here, but I just hate Hasan. So I'm going
to [__] on this all goddamn day.
All goddamn day.
DUDE, [laughter] THAT'S INSANE.
WHY? WHY? DUDE, YOU COULD JUST TAKE A 2-DAY BREAK from hating
everything about Hasan and go, "Actually, this is really cool.
This is really cool. This whole Cuban thing is really cool, actually."
Right? Just take a break. You can take 2 days off of hating Hasan.
He's going to come back. He's going to say something about American
politics. And then you pick up you're off to the races. Why not
chill for two goddamn seconds
on the snark and just let the aid come in. Let the charity come
in. It's It's It could be so easy, man. Big boy took a boat with
the solar panels. I don't know who Big Boy is.
Oh, also, dude, it's so funny that she said it's all white men
there.
It's all white men there. And then this is [clears throat] This
is literally a part of the video. The guy looking down. It's
the same video.
Are these people Were these people in the convoy?
All these white men. ALL THESE WHITE men
Okay, hold on. Who's this Who's this Big Boy? Big Sorry, Boy
Boy. Not Big Boy, but Boy Boy. Oh, right. Yeah. Oh, yeah. We
want We looked at this. I remember this guy.
Stacks of solar panels and 30 tons of humanitarian aid headed
to Cuba. Headed to Cuba.
We We looked at this one already. Yeah.
Boom. Bunch of solar panels traveled across the ocean. By the
way, this is some crazy [__] This boat doesn't look
that big. I would not I could I couldn't do it, man. I couldn't
cross the ocean like this. I died Dude, I'd have a panic attack
on this boat. I don't even know. Ryan Grim explains the hotel
situation. Okay, I got it. Yeah, I got I got it. I got it. I
got it. Thank you. We could look at this after. I
Fine, you know what? We'll look at it right now. Give me a second.
Let's finish this clip and then I'll look at the Ryan Grim tweet.
He made a big thing about it. And if you know what? If that's
what it was to just make a lot of noise so that we can see that
other people are doing
then that's interesting and that's that's, you know, that that
could be taken as a positive.
>> But it just the whole thing seems seems bizarre. It
just seems It just seems weird. I mean, listen, he could have
got there and been like, "This sucks. I got to get out of here."
He may have done that.
We'll never know. We'll never We'll never know.
Guys, hypothetically, wait, did I hear that correctly? It just
seems It just seems weird. I mean, listen, he could have got
there and been like, "This sucks. I got to get out of here."
He may Hypothetically, guys, Hasan could have been at the concert.
Think about that. This concert that killed people, Hasan might
have been there. Hypothetically, we'll never know. So think about
that. That You guys thinking about that? Like possibly, even
though we'd never know, I want you to imagine that Hasan was
there.
>> Right? You got Think about that. Just think about it,
Awesome. Love you guys. Okay, let's do the Ryan Grim tweet and
then we will continue on.
Hold on. Where's my Ryan Grim tweet? Back does, I understand
that you dislike Hasan. That's That's fine. We can dislike Hasan.
Sorry, I I appreciate that you're willing to say on this one
thing you could look the other way. Looks really bad to just
go after these people for this.
Thank you. Thank you.
All right.
Here's another complaint from the Free Press. Viral content creators
like Hasan [__] and Ryan Grim were invited for a
weekend in a blacked-out Cuba so they could preach the glories
of la
That's not what happened. In fact, shockingly little streaming
was
Here's another complaint from the Free Press that a hotel had
power while hospital lost power in Cuba. In case the Free Press
is merely ignorant and not actively lying to their audience,
I'd remind them that the Trump administration changed its rules
so private businesses like the American-owned hotels that Americans
are required to stay in are allowed to buy imported oil from
the government, which means all hospitals are not allowed to
import oil.
Oh, wait. No. There's no way that's the rule. Then by definition,
Hasan's not staying in one of the illegal hotels because they
were probably running on generators where they could buy oil
from them, right? That would explain
Bro, there's no way that's actually what happened. THAT LOOKS
SO BAD FOR ALL THESE PEOPLE. ACTUALLY, the American government
is the reason I I'd have to see some evidence of this, too, probably.
But that would be crazy, right? That would be crazy if this were
the case. I don't know I don't know where you find more info
on this. Oh, Ryan's going to do more info. Okay, keep reading
the So now that the Free Press is aware of this fact and rightly
thinks it is wrong to deprive the a hospital fuel, I'm sure they
will amend this piece and join the rest of the civilized world
in demanding Trump end this illegal oil blockade, right? That's
what they'll do, won't Oh, no. Okay. It's the US government that
requires Americans to stay at these hotels and there there are
only four or five of them. There'd be more if not for the blockade
or restrictions on tourism. And all of them are so-called five
stars. So that criticism is missing important context, too. Oh,
wait. Wait, Hasan was literally required Oh, no.
There's no way I See, I always push back against this cuz this
is like This is making me correct in every possible dimension.
So that seems like it's too good to be true.
But could you imagine if literally all of the hotels are so-called
five-star hotels and he actually was
forced to stay in a in a five-star hotel and all of these people
are wrong. Do you think any of them will update their audience?
Hasan wasn't making it up? I Listen, I'm going to have to see
some I would love for Ryan to just show some sources on this
for like where he like called and asked people or
Cuz I Trust me, when something's this good, I'm very hesitant
immediately, okay? He's literally saying it's just what the US
calls a five-star hotel. Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure. So-called
five-star hotels. Got it. We're required to stay there, then
criticized for staying there by the people who support the US
policy that requires we stay there. Probably genuine ignorance
from the Free Press on on this point. Although that's not an
excuse for a thing that calls itself a news outlet. These facts
are findable. Right?
Listen, if a Twitter account made this mistake, that would be
understandable.
But you're a journalistic outlet. You are the whole You're trying
to do real journalism. That's why you got a $200 deal for your
company, isn't it, Bari Weiss? That you guys do real and honest
But did you call anybody? Did you look anything up? No. Ryan
Grim was there. Okay, I got it. Ryan Grim does seem like the
kind of guy that would cross his cross his t's and dot his i's
on this. That he would make sure. Right? There was a period of
time in my own life, Chinese Nick Mullen. What the [__]
>> There's a period of time in my life or in my own lifetime
that an article like this, riddled with errors, would embarrass
a news organization, whether it was left, right, or center. That
time is past. Zero chance at Bari Weiss is even remotely bothered
by by it or that any corrections or clarifications will be issued.